hello in this video we are going to do
an introduction on how Google optimize
storage on persistent desks to increase
database performance and why we can
disable safely the double write feature
in MySQL even though everybody
recommends not doing it heavy that in
mind we are proud to announce that in
the past 12 months the performance of
cloud Seco for MySQL and Postgres has
doubled according to the benchmarks when
moving from 128 to 256 threads show the
performance a change of a thousand 500
TPS through 3,000 TPS not bad it's not
enough to show performance more
importantly it's to show consistent
performance one of the keys to get this
type of performance for your own
deployments realize inserting some
custom Flags or system variables for
instance I know the B log file size I
know the B i/o capacity and max allowed
packet to understand what which of those
flags and system variables does I
recommend you to check out this URL the
results are incredible all the scatter
performance points seem to now converge
to a better alignment and when you have
your configuration set just right you
get results like this where scatter
performance converges to a more
consistent alignment the main factors
driving this change in performance lying
disabling double writes in the I know
the P engine I know what you're thinking
why are you doing something that
everybody recommends you not to why is
Google taking such a risk with my data
the secret has to do with understanding
how block sizes influences performance
at each layer on the first layer we have
the persistent disk allowing 16
kilobytes as physical block for writes
on the second layer we have the ext4
filesystem using a feature called
bigger lock that allows for 16 kilobyte
cluster size
this is why the 16 kilobyte esis allows
us to disable double write safely the
third layer involves our container
optimized alas you may have heard about
it in kubernetes and at last we have
MySQL I know the B configure to have
double write off and to use the all
direct as a flush method in a simplified
way these four layers are the key
components of the 16 kilobyte instance
or engineers work in collaboration with
multiple teams to make this happen if
you want to know more details as how we
did it with confidence watch the talk oh
and by the way you don't have to take my
word for it or benchmarking code is open
source as perf kit benchmark er it can
be found at github and will let you
compare performance for various products
across several cloud providers check out
the full talk for more in the trenches
details and don't forget to subscribe to
our channel for more great next rewind
content
[Music]